こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日は
ですねサウナに来ているんですけども
男性の皆さんお待たせいたしましたどうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
可愛い女の子たちの準備しましたー
[音楽]
[拍手]
水着
美女がたくさん入ってくるとどうなるの
俺はもう男の夢の企画ですよ皆さんサウナ
入られると思うんですけどもサウナって
基本的によくあるのが男女が別れてるん
ですよ
男というと女湯みたいに巻かれてると思う
んですけれども
それずっと気がつってしまうのでなんで
だろう男湯と女に別れてるので基本的に
男湯のサウナ男のサウナに
女の子が入ってくることってないと思うん
ですけども今回ですねこちら
新宿のテルマエさん貸切でございます
[拍手]
基本的に誰もいない男のサウナなんです
けども
男湯なので絶対女性が来ることがない中で
なんとかしてターゲットを1人ポツンと
さらにいる状態にしたところで皆さんに
突撃していただきたいと思っております
[音楽]
[拍手]
貸切サウナだ
嬉しいこれ
[音楽]
全部貸切か
熱い
[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですそして
気をつけてー
撮影しております
でここすごい有名ですたくさん人も入るの
で
走るのやばいんですよこれ実は
めちゃめちゃデカかったですねなんで
貸し切れてるかというと
[音楽]
買収しました
けどそういうのは営業してるからなかなか
入れない自分のサウナというより本当に
ビジネスのということでただこんな素敵な
施設なかなか使えることないんでちょっと
いつもサウナでいく仲間を何か連れて一緒
に入ろうということでありがとうじゃあ
楽しんでいきなさい
[音楽]
はいどうですかこれ
素晴らしい
素晴らしいでしょ
素晴らしいです最高ですそれでサウナ
行こうかそれでもね
行ってみましょうかよろしくお願いします
失礼しますどうぞ
最高だねこれは
[音楽]
私は整いますよこれが初めてか
あちょっと
忘れ物をしたらはい詰まってください
整ってていいよ
歌詞きりだから何でもいいと思ってさなん
でもいいよ
マジで寝っ転がったらいいか寝転がったら
いいんですよ失礼します
[音楽]
最高
そういうのもあり
ます
かね
ーよあっついマジで
ちょうど見過ぎで
えマジで頑張りますよねこれこれ
[音楽]
水着美女がいっぱい入ってきたらどうする
のも注意でしたー
すごいサバになってくれました
すごいよ
今回もよかったです
[音楽]
あったかい
どうぞ座ってくださいどこでもいいどこで
もいいよ失礼します
[音楽]
どういやいいっすね
ちょっと一人で入ってて一緒にトイレ行っ
てくる
[拍手]
[音楽]
や
[拍手]
[音楽]
ば
何も反応できなかった
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですそして
はいどうも水沢亮のKANAですお願いし
ます患者さんですよろしくお願いします
ありがとうございます
サンタさんは
サウナ好きですか
あーでも割と行きますよあ本当に結構なん
かあんまりイメージなかったからいや
なんか一番初めはしばゆーに誘われて
結構行くようになってで今は結構
週12ぐらいでは
結構いってるねでサウナなんですけども
熱っぱしってわかりますよねあれですよね
今回
[音楽]
世界ランク1位の方呼んでおります
探偵の仕方とかよくわかんないんだけど
それで世界
ということで
実際にそれを今回我々新宿テルマエという
超有名な際の2人で体験していきたいと
思いますありがとうございます
だって始めさんに呼んでもらうとバスケ
出させてもらった200万円ぐらいもらっ
たなんかそういうまあ割といいことあるん
でどんなに熱くされても文句言えない
みたいだからその後水が入って入ってると
絶対気持ちいいから
是非熱くなってくださいはいじゃあ行き
ましょうはいというわけで患者さん早速
サラダ入っていきましょういきます普通に
そもそもサワーはなかったかいっていう
熱い
ガッツですね
怖すぎよし来るぞ
熱っぱしが開きましたよろしくお願いし
ますよろしくお願いしますお願いします
それでは早速あります
自然な感じで
すごいな本格的だね
[音楽]
すごいよ
すごいっしょ
[音楽]
すごいすごい
特別の
頭のつむじを仰ぐというサービスござい
まして
頭のつむじが熱感じやすいので
グッと
怖い
負けていただいて
スムーズに風を送っていきますはい
目も閉じていただいて
マジで怖いっす
頭爆発するんじゃないのか
優しい風邪から
[音楽]
上げていきます
そんなに家で見たことないですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
それでは強い風は
[音楽]
本当に暑いし
ワイン水着をいっぱい上の熱を使える
んですよね
声がまたちょっと
上げていきますハンターそうそう水風呂
行くじゃん
[拍手]
[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですそして
大和小湊ですよろしくお願いしますよく来
ていただきました
なんと時刻
朝の4時でございます
[音楽]
貸し出しなんですかそうか差し出して山と
貸し出しております今日はいよろしくお
願いします
クリエイターで結構サウナ好きな方って
多いんですけどももう好きじゃかなり
大好きですねもうサウナ歩きほんと3年目
とかな
もうそういうサウナと呼ばれるとちょっと
集めてちょっと重大発表させてください俺
ここ
新宿の有名店舗テルマーニーさんなんと私
はじめしゃちょー
買収しました
クッチっすか4ただその一般開放してるん
で
貸切っていうのがなかなかこう書いてでも
できなくてこういう時間になっちゃったん
ですけど
大詰め楽しんでいて
買収とかあるいや僕来たことあって
本当に
初めて血みたいなことですよもう実質家
ですね僕はもう
来ましたー
こちらです
こちら
サングラスでございます
会話しちゃダメなんですけども今回
貸し切りということで話題ですよ
失礼します
[音楽]
いいんですかもう
ゆっくりしよう
うわマジで最後です俺初めてなんですよ
サウナ
[音楽]
中で本当に
俺も多分持ってくるあっつ
[音楽]
[拍手]
学生の人
いきます
[拍手]
[音楽]
きつかったらOKって言ってもらえれば
やめる
[音楽]
というわけで山本さんサウナ入ってたら
水着美女とたくさん入ってくるドッキリ
でしたー
水着の美女めっちゃいると思います
言わないでもうオープニングで最初に
いきなり水着美女来るんですかって言って
たから
すごくないですか
すごいよもう初めにドッキリかけられすぎ
てサウナはじめだったら絶対水着美女大量
に入れるだろう
なんでわかったのマジでパリじゃないです
か
ゆっくりできました普段のではできない
タイプだと思うんですけどそれを結構
楽しみにしてきたじゃあ楽しめた
楽しみましたよ
いやありがとうございました